[Music]
my next gas is a committee in whom we
featured a number of times over the
years today is releasing his debut
comedy album 100% half asked from our
very own team Coco records for more
information and to download it go to
team cocoa records dot-com please
welcome back to the show the very funny
Ian Edwards
[Applause]
how's everybody feeling good I like that
you look like an honest crowd so I just
want to take a quick survey see you
walking down the street late at night
and you see two black dudes in hoodies
coming your way how many people here
honestly would cross over to the other
side of the street so one person in the
top and me that's it
arrests y'all just be straight dishonest
huh let me tell you why cross street I
cross street because the news tells me
every night that black dudes in hoodies
are dangerous there is a black dude in a
hoodie story on the news every night no
matter what's going on in the world and
back from Afghanistan to these black
dudes and hoodies oh I wish I was safely
in war-torn Afghanistan away from these
black dudes in hoodies like the news
make it so bad I seen a black dude in a
hoodie cross the street when he seen
another black dude in a hood
amen I want no problems player I want
none either bro grandma is that you
[Music]
because the news tell us what to think
about all the different races they set
the stereotypes every night but what the
news doesn't tell us is that men in
suits are the biggest robbers and the
biggest criminals hands down don't sing
like Bernie Madoff was one dude in a
suit he stole more money than every
black dude in the history of hoodies
combined you don't say he stole 65
billion dollars black dudes in hoodies
and mugged a million yet one dude in a
suit out stole an entire race right next
time you walk in that Street you see a
man in a suit cross over and warn the
black dude in a hoodie he's in danger
save his life do something and that's
why I'm glad Obama's president cuz
finally black people have a good
representative you know saying before we
had some bad black representatives we
had al Sharpton al Sharpton is not a
good look for black people no he'll come
on
people are hey man there goes your
leader like I didn't nominate this dude
my leader you know what it feels like to
have out Sharpton as your leader white
people imagine if Hulk Hogan was your
racial leader
every time something goes down he comes
on news ah you know Mean Gene we're
gonna shut this racism down by wise I'll
leader ripping off his shirt kissing his
muscles before that we had Jesse Jackson
a lot of people think Jesse Jackson is a
good leader but Jesse Jackson is not a
good leader this how you know Jesse
Jackson's not a good leader cuz nobody
ever tried to kill him it is
disrespectful to have a black leader
that nobody wants to kill
this how you know Jesse Jackson was
really not a good leader the person who
shot Martin Luther King had a clear shot
at Jesse Jackson too and that thing just
packed up his rifle
and went home you know say yeah he's
gonna do more damage alive
now I was watching the news
saw the story about this guy he did
thirty years in jail for something he
didn't do and they finally found out and
let him out and I was happy for him but
let me tell you something if I think
thirty years in jail for something I
didn't do
when I get out I'm gonna do something
that's 30 years credit you know I've
already done the time that was time to
do the crime
[Music]
I got a prepaid crime credit card I'm
just gonna commit crimes and swipe doop
yes officer
excuse me talk to me get the hell out my
face officer I'll be back in court the
next day the judge be looking at me like
mr. Edwards says here we let you out
yesterday you just robbed the gas
station with an ice pick I'm like that's
right sir that's a year take it off my
card and hurry up I got a lot more stuff
I got to do I got banks to rob and drugs
to sell it's matter of fact I like were
you looking at me judge get the hell out
here five years take it off my card and
don't let me use the rest of it up in
this Court
all right that's my time my name is Ian
Ayre was